failed former vice president Mike Pence
who is as much who basically failed as
hard as Trump did has been asked about
the verdict in which a jury found Donald
Trump liable for sexual assault and
defamation against e Gene Carroll Mike
Pence's reaction is I dare say
kafka-esque
he says he never saw Trump sexually
assault anyone
think about that for a second what do
you think about that verdict listen I
never saw Trump sexually assault anybody
wow big declaration Mike thank you let's
listen see in my four and a half years
serving alongside the president I I
never heard or witnessed
behavior of that nature
I never personally witnessed Charles
Manson encouraged those people to go and
kill anybody he must not have done it
right a truly
spineless response from Mike Pence we
also had Pence weighing in on whether
the American people will in any way be
influenced by the fact that Trump now is
not only has been arrested and indicted
and might be arrested and indicted again
in a couple of months but was found
liable for sexual assault he says Pence
does he doesn't think the American
people will care well I think that's a
question for the American people but I I
really can't comment on a judgment in a
civil case I have no knowledge of those
matters and um uh I'm sure the president
uh will defend himself in that matter
and
um but it strikes me that we it's a it's
just one more instance where
at a time when American families are
struggling he's really he's really
struggling to figure out what to say
about this to remain palatable to the
Maga crowd in case he does run
when our economy is hurting when the
world seems to become a more dangerous
place
almost every day that it's uh it's just
one more story uh focusing on my former
running mate that that I I know is a
great Fascination to members of the
national media but I just I just don't
think it's where the American people are
focused all right the American people
don't care because of inflation I guess
or something along those lines to me
that sounds like a guy who wants to say
whatever he can say to not anger the
very Maga people who maybe if Trump gets
arrested again and his campaign falls
apart for whatever reason Pence can jump
in and say I'm going to run Mega people
who supported Trump back when I was VP
come with me to the promised land or
whatever the case may be may be one of
the most cowardly
spineless and self-serving people in
American politics right now would be
indeed Mike Pence and the the height of
absurdity of
I never saw him engage in that sort of
behavior really does do you think he
does does a Serial sexual assaulter
habitually do the assaulting in front of
other men I mean I don't know there was
the allegation
about Jeffrey Epstein and Trump doing
exactly that but uh not the vast
majority of the allegations that exist
so Penn's pathetic is always polling
like three or four percent in most polls
six seven in some and maybe thinking
opportunistically is this uh let's leave
it with the question that was asked
will that civil liability verdict
affect Trump's standing in either the
primary or the general I actually agree
that the answer is no but for a
different reason than Mike Pence says I
think in the primary it won't affect
Trump at least not negatively because
for as many people in the Republican
primary voter electorate that would be
turned off by Trump being liable for
sexual assault there are those who will
be re-engaged because they believe Trump
is being treated unfairly and that it's
all a political Witch Hunt so in the
primary it'll probably be flat in the
general
um
I think that the cake is more or less
baked and it's basically a turnout thing
and maybe there are some people who
would turn out because they're angry
that Trump uh engaged in this behavior
and they want to vote against him but
it's also not clear to me that it's
going to shift the numbers in a general
election either I know it's crazy I know
it's crazy but that's where my head is
right now let me know what you think
when there's a non-fiction book I just
don't have the time to read having a
summary of the book is really valuable
several different platforms out there
will summarize books I've tried them all
short form is by far the most impressive
one and it goes Way Beyond what other
platforms do our sponsor short form not
only will Summarize the book covering
all of the key ideas short form also
provides analysis and commentary that
contextualizes the book comparing it to
what other books say about the same
topic and you can read or listen to the
entire thing in one sitting for instance
the book dark money by Jane Mayer about
how wealthy Republicans are covertly
influencing American politics short form
clearly and concisely sums up the book's
most important takeaways but it also
gives you a ton of other crucial
background about lobbying libertarianism
and that helps you really understand how
does the book fit into the broader topic
of conservative money in politics that's
why I love short form short form has
every genre politics business Tech
biographies and my audience can try
short form totally free and get 25 off a
subscription at Short form.com Pacman
the link is down below